The Joe Rogan experience.
Did you ever fuck would you do to know?
I the,
I always wanted to,
but did you check?
I thought about it and uh,
I on down the 10th planet,
man,
he fit right in.
I think I will,
you know,
like a lot of people have asked me and invited me cause they know,
a UFC fan.
I'm a mixed martial arts fan.
I'm a boxing fan,
you know,
all that shit at,
a couple of my cousins are low.
One of them was a champion professional boxer,
which was Michael Carbo Hall and his nephews.
Your cousins.
Yes.
My cousin,
I met my goal.
I met him one day at the comedy store.
Yeah.
Long time ago,
man.
Yeah,
when he was a,
when he was a champ,
he was a beast.
He was a beast and his,
uh,
nephew is now now boxing Keenan Carbo.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
So yeah.
You know,
we're rooting for family right there,
but Arizona,
right?
Yeah.
For Maisy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
yeah,
I've,
I've been invited to,
to,
you know,
come fuck with some Jujitsu and,
and I think I,
you know,
I think I will because I mean,
you got to know it.
I think,
I think you,
you know,
it's something that would benefit anyone from to know that.
Yeah.
So that you don't actually,
you know,
get in a fight and have to hurt somebody bad or they hurt you.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Just choke him.
Just choke him out.
I saw Everlast choke some guy out one night and it was the fucking,
cause you know,
he,
he fucks around a little bit.
You know,
he knows people that teach Jujitsu and they've taught them a couple of things.
We're at the rainbow one night where we were holding court,
I'm just smoking like it's Amsterdam down there.
And we were having a conversation and he kept hearing some dude across cross a
couple of tables over,
kept saying Everlast this Everlast that and he,
he,
your money saved my day and one more time.
And he goes,
Everlast
and he went back to talking to his people because he did the Everlast was good.
Come up.
And Dude that the d Everlast went and walked over to this table,
look to his face,
turned them around real quick and start choking him.
Say My name again.
Muddy saying,
Jesus.
Oh man,
it was,
it was hilarious.
But uh,
yeah,
man.